look at the two thermometers below
identify which is celsius and which is
fahrenheit and then label the boiling
and freezing points of water on each now
the celsius scale is what's used in most
of the world so the celsius scale
celsius
celsius is most of the world
most of
the world
and the easy way to tell that you're
dealing with the celsius scales on the
on the celsius scale
zero degrees is
freezing of water
freezing at of water at standard
temperature and pressure and 100 degrees
is the boiling point
the boiling point of water at standard
temperature and pressure now on the
fahrenheit scale
fahrenheit which is used mainly in the
united states
fahrenheit scale
the freezing point of water is 32
degrees
32 degrees is freezing
32 degrees is freezing and boiling of
water is 212 degrees
boiling of water is 212 degrees as you
can tell celsius the whole scale came
from using freezing is zero of regular
water at standard temperature and
pressure and setting a hundred to be
boiling and so on some level makes a
little bit more logical sense but at
least here in the u.s we still use
fahrenheit now let's figure out which of
these are fahrenheit which are celsius
now remember regardless of which
thermometer you're using water will
always actually boil at the exact same
temperature so fahrenheit 32 degrees
this has to be the same thing as celsius
zero degrees so let's see what happens
so when this temperature right here is 0
this one over here looks like it's
negative something so this one right
here doesn't look like celsius here if
we say this is celsius this looks pretty
close to 32 on this one so this one
right here looks like let me do that in
a darker color
so this one right here looks like
celsius
celsius and this one right here looks
like fahrenheit
fair in height and the way i was able to
tell is that the zero degrees celsius
needs to be the same thing as 32 degrees
fahrenheit that in both cases this is
where this right here is where water
freezes
the freezing point
that is water freezing and let's make
sure we're right so this is a celsius
scale this is where water will boil 100
degrees celsius and that looks like it
is right about 212 on the other scale so
right there is where water is boiling
water is boiling at standard temperature
and pressure so this thing on the right
right here i guess i'll circle it in
orange
that is
that is celsius and then the one on the
left i'll do it in magenta
the one on the left is fahrenheit